back in 2010 when director Li Anchorage
first pitched his idea to make cocoa it
was going to be a completely different
movie than the one we know and love
today
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal
some of the dramatic changes that Pixar
made to its 19th feature film during the
course of its development by the way I'm
running a giveaway for this gorgeous art
of cocoa hardback book filled with
stunning concept art for all my
subscribers to enter leave a comment
below with your thoughts about the cocoa
movie we never got to see and make sure
you're subscribed to my channel quick
warning I will be talking spoilers for
the movie so take care if you've not
seen it yet originally cocoa is going to
be a full-on
traditional musical which would have
been a first for Pixar yes the film was
going to feature six full-length songs
including several show-stopping song and
dance numbers all written by Robert
Lopez and Kristen anderson-lopez the
husband-and-wife songwriting team behind
Disney's frozen Coco's creators even
toyed with the idea of naming the film
remember me after add mr. delacro's
biggest hit which was the first song
they composed indeed speaking on the qat
podcast with jeff goldsmith cocoa
screenwriters revealed this in early
versions of the movie
Miguel's ancestors in the land of the
dead were all cursed so they couldn't
talk but could only communicate by
singing which they all hated because as
we know only too well from the final
film that Iveta family absolutely hates
music the filmmakers worked on this
full-on musical version of Coco for
several years before eventually
abandoning that idea as they felt it
just wasn't working that's when they
took inspiration from films such as once
and Oprah than where art thou and
instead of having the characters in Coco
burst into song about their feelings
they decided to only include music that
was driven by actual performances for
example when Miguel sings on stage in
the land of the dead
or when Ector sings to Cheech are on
which was a scene that co-writer and
co-director Adrian Molina came up with
for the team behind Coco this new
approach felt truer to the kind of tale
they wanted to tell and it also meant
they could showcase more Mexican
influenced music and make more use of
the extensive research they carried out
the film on top of that it also gave the
filmmakers more time to concentrate on
the emotional side of the story they
were telling however just because Coco
changed from being a full of musical
doesn't mean that everything the
filmmakers worked on in that initial
version was thrown out
for example the papel picado sequence
which opens the final film actually
started life as part of a musical number
in the middle of the movie
speaking of Coco's opening scenes that
part of the film changed several times
over the course of the film's
development initially the movie was
going to begin with a full-on musical
number called the other los cuartos
featuring performers on stage in 1950s
Mexico City the filmmakers thought the
song and dance routine would help
introduce the idea of the Day of the
Dead
especially to viewers who hadn't grown
up with that particular tradition so the
deleted opening scene includes important
items for the holiday for example the
ofrenda and also set up to honor a
person's ancestors food such as
Calaveras or sugar skulls pan de muerto
or sweet rolls and male sauce and also
marigolds which you can see throughout
the performance this deleted scene was
actually the first scene that adrian
molina storyboarded on the movie and
there's much to enjoy about it including
the catchy chew which emphasizes the
celebratory nature of the day the dead
and there's lots of clever little
touches too like the Marigold design
that the parasols carried by the female
dancers and the way the altar transforms
into a skull and finally a full skeleton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the end the filmmakers decided to cut
the musical opening as instead they
wanted us to meet the movie's main
character Miguel straight away so we
could learn all about him and his family
and their polar opposite feelings about
music and lots more songs ended up
getting the chop after the directors
decided against making it its new star
musical one of those songs was from the
film's first act it was called way of
the Rivera's basically Miguel's family
sings to him about what it means to be a
member of the Rivera family and how he
must continue their traditions like it
or not which essentially means that he
has to make shoes Roth has the music and
to emphasize that point at the end of
the song Miguel's grandmother swipes his
guitar away from him now I'm not a huge
fan of this particular song but it gets
across the idea of family obligation
that it was going for however it does
seem rather odd to have the Rivera's
break into song to express themselves
when a major plot point of the movie is
that the Rivera family absolutely hates
music and that's exactly what the
creators of Coco realized wasn't working
about the full-on musical version of the
film
[Music]
[Music]
that was very educational
now can I borrow your workbench well the
way of the Nevada's tune didn't make us
into the final film the movie does
include a scene that gets the same point
across by showing Miguel's relatives
telling him that from now on after his
school days finished he'll join them
working in their family shoemaking
business because as they tell him you
are re better and adi vera is a
shoemaker through and through however
the music wasn't the only major change
that Coco underwent during its six years
of production director Lee Unkrich his
original idea for Coco was to tell the
tale of a young boy in the United States
whose father was American and whose
mother was Mexican in the script for
that initial story the boy visits Mexico
for the Day of the Dead and as he faces
his grief for his mother who's passed
away he eventually learns to move on and
let go of her of course approaching the
story in this way would have meant that
Coco would have been told from an
entirely different perspective
specifically an American one what really
changed the filmmakers mind was this
after several research trips to Mexico
and everything they discovered about
deer they murdered us they realized that
the story they were planning to tell
about grief and letting go of a loved
one who's died was not what the Day of
the Dead was actually about instead
encouraged said he learned that deer de
Muertos isn't about grieving it's a
celebration it's about remembering those
family members and loved ones who passed
and keeping them close so the team
behind Coco decided to ditch their
initial story idea and focus instead on
the themes of family and music setting
the movie entirely in Mexico now would
you have liked to see Coco as a full-on
musical movie and what did you enjoy
most about the final film let me know in
the comments below and also make sure
you subscribe for a chance to win this
beautiful art of Coco book if you
enjoyed this remember to like and share
and hit the notification bell to get all
my new videos and you can also tap the
screen here to check out all the Easter
eggs you missed in Coco plus some other
cool Pixar videos thanks for watching
and see you next time you became ooh be
love